un eric verhaeghe fondateur du courrier
des stratèges eric verhaeghe bonsoir
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
du monde dans les rues aujourd'hui un
contre cet article 24 de la loi sécurité
globale vous vous y attendiez en tout
cas on peut constater que depuis
plusieurs semaines la polémique sur
cette loi ne désenfle pas ne diminue pas
au contraire elle ne fait que que
progresser et ce qui est très frappant
mon point de vue c'est qu'elle touche
des partis au fond très différente de la
population se dire qu'on voit qu'il ya
pas mal de mouvements de gauche qui sont
présents sur cette manifestation mais le
rejet de la loi touche une population
beaucoup plus large que les mouvements
politiques actifs à gauche
elle touche aussi des fractions très
libérale de l'opinion beaucoup plus à
droite
et de ce point de vue on voit bien qu'il
ya quelque chose qui est qui est
beaucoup plus que de l'ordre de
l'activisme politique si vous voulez on
sent que cette toile est en train de de
toucher aux tréfonds du pays et qu'elle
est en train d'agiter de nourrir des
craintes qui en est fait assez
naturellement mobilise très largement là
où on peut s'étonner c'est qu'une grande
partie de vos collègues ou concurrentes
autres chaînes notamment de shy'm
mainstream sont beaucoup moins pro actif
que vous sur l'information concernant
les libertés publiques ce que beaucoup
plus du procès de johnattan d'aval août
autres et est donc l'opinion peut se
considérer comme sous informés
aujourd'hui sur cette question autant
sur le contenu la loi que sur la colère
qu'elle suscite donc c'est quand même un
événement important significatif positif
de mon point de vue que de voir que
malgré cette source d'information une
grande partie de la plus claire beaucoup
de gens sont allés manifester on l'a vu
dans dont les images au trocadéro où il
y avait probablement plus de 5000
peut-être plus de dix mille personnes
présentes sur les lieux
sur cette question et eric verhaeghe
l'extrême gauche et la droite libérale
vous lisiez sur rejoigne mais sur quels
points précisément je pense qu'il ya une
crainte aujourd'hui très profonde de
voir ce que un certain temps de voter -
ont appelé la dictature sommet taxes et
qui est un terme qui puce utilisée dans
la droite libérale d'ailleurs que dans
la gauche aujourd'hui
alors cette dictature elle se manifeste
par part par des actes forts l'article
24 de la loi de sécurité globale qui
prévoit de restreindre très fortement le
droit de films étaient des policiers les
manifestations ou des des actions
policières
mais je parle aussi très volontiers
souvent de l'article 21 qui prévoit
l'utilisation très large de drones
équipés de caméras de surveillance qui
permettront de la reconnaissance faciale
en temps réel non grâce à la loi qui est
en discussion une manifestation comme
celle du trocadéro permettrait
d'identifier immédiatement tous les
opposants au régime et on sait par le
passé comment ce genre de disposition un
permis d'établir des régimes de
répression y compris en france
je posais la question également au
précédent 1 l'idée est ce que c'est une
réelle volonté du gouvernement selon
vous ou alors est-ce que effectivement
ça montre une improvisation une
maladresse un certain amateurisme même
pour reprendre le mot alors moi je suis
ce que je suis pas juste des intentions
des gens je ne connais que les actes ce
que je vois c'est qu'il ya six ou sept
ans on a mis en place un fichier d
assurance vie et des contrats
d'assurance vie existant en france avec
le montant sur ces contrats
officiellement pour préparer protéger
les assurés vie les assurés sur la vie
et la semaine dernière le sénat a
autorisé le contrôle de ce fichier la
consultation ce fichier par les agents
de pôle emploi qui vont donc maintenant
flics et les chômeurs sur l'éventuelle
leur éventuelle détention d'un
patrimoine
on voit bien comment une loi lorsqu'elle
est adopté on dit mais non c'est la
protection c'est pour protéger ce qui
nous protège et c est 5 ans 10 ans plus
tard ça devient une arme incontrôlable
est un outil extraordinaire de
violations des libertés publiques ne
pourront ne fait pas une loi pour
qu'elle dure un an ou deux on fait une
loi pour qu'elle dure longtemps et
l'utilisation qu'on pourra faire de
cette loi dans dix ans elle me paraît
redoutable parce que plus personne ne se
souviendra de ce qu'a dit gérald
darmanin à l'assemblée nationale le jour
où il a fait adopter tout le monde lire
à la loi et se dira mais cette loi
permet d'identifier les gens qui
prennent le métro faire la
reconnaissance sociale comme en chine et
de les noter sur leur comportement
citoyen ce sera possible grâce à cette
loi
la loi interdira de filmer des actions
policières lorsqu elle viole
manifestement les libertés et les droits
de l'homme et donc le problème n'est pas
ce que le gouvernement a l'intention de
faire de cette loi dans les six mois le
problème c'est ce à quoi la loi servira
dans cinq ans dans dix ans nul ne sait
qui sera élu président de la république
en 2022
nul ne sait qui sera élu présent la
république en 2027 et nul ne sait quelle
utilisation la personne qui arrivera à
l'elysée à ce moment là pour affaires de
cette loi qui accorde un pouvoir
extraordinairement disproportionné aux
forces de police est dans une démocratie
libérale
on ne peut pas accepter ça moi ce qui me
gêne si vous voulez c'est que j'ai très
souvent entendu
emmanuel macron faire la leçon aux
démocraties qui l'appelle libéral à la
hongrie à la pologne à la russie a
d'autres et aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
que se dote d'un arsenal législatif que
peu de démocratie libérale ont à leur
disposition
et ça c'est un vrai problème si vous
voulez c'est qu'à force d'expliquer que
nous on est d'aider des gens libres et
des respectueuse de respectueux des
droits et des libertés publiques
on se permet de les violer allègrement
et d'organiser
leur massacre en série dans les années à
venir et ça si vous voulez c'est une
ligne rouge que le gouvernement est en
train de franchir que les démocrates ne
peuvent pas accepter entendait nicolas
vidal parler des médias meanstream il ya
effectivement eu une tribune qui est
paru alors avec tout un tas de médias
assez opposées finalement la croix le
figaro ou même libération est ce que ça
veut dire quelque chose de fort tout de
même c'était cette tribune je crois que
ça fait c'est le répétition quelque
chose de fort puisque souvenez-vous
lorsque nicolas sarkozy est arrivé il a
demandé à ce que les journalistes ne
siège plus dans les locaux de l'elysée
dans la salle de presse de l'elysée et
il a tenu systématiquement à mettre les
journalistes à l'écart
je crois que sur la chaîne arte vous
êtes assez bien placé pour savoir qu
père nicolas sarkozy que la sarko six
mois emmanuel macron lapsus c'est
étrange
emmanuel macron à une politique
d'accréditation d'un certain nombre de
journalistes qui est particulière
répétez là encore par gérald arbres
anaky a expliqué que si les journalistes
il ya quelques jours que si les journées
ne voulait pas se faire interpeller sur
les lieux d'une manifestation il fallait
d'abord qu'il se rapproche des autorités
pour être accrédités pour couvrir
l'événement donc on voit bien qu'il y a
une très grande continuité et que depuis
son arrivée au pouvoir emmanuel macron
n'a jamais caché que pour lui la presse
c'était quelque chose qui devait
transmettre la parole officielle et que
l'esprit critique des journalistes va
être limitée aux ou entouré ce qui pose
problème quand même dans toute cette
affaire c'est qu'on voit bien que la
police aujourd'hui les forces de police
ont un poids grandissant dans l'appareil
d'état
on ne peut pas ignorer que cet
accroissement du pouvoir de la police de
l'influencent policière dans dans les
institutions françaises est devenu
criant avec l'opération des gilet jaune
c'est à dire que
souvenez-vous là aussi le 17 novembre
2018 lorsque les gilet jaune descendent
dans la rue on s'aperçoit que le pouvoir
n'a rien anticiper qu'il est tellement
déconnectés de la réalité qui n'a rien
vu venir et que pendant plusieurs mois
jusqu'au grand débat qui commence de
mémoire en février d'ailleurs pendant
quatre ans à 4 mois
emmanuel macron en garde un silence
politique complet sur les bancs et
souvenez-vous de ce 3 décembre 2018 où
le régime est à genoux et où ne tient
plus que par la police et donc
aujourd'hui on a un vrai sujet dans ce
pays c'est que d'une façon ou d'une
autre
emmanuel macron est profondément
dépendant de la police et de
l'intervention policière et je vais même
plus loin de la répression policière
pour garder le pouvoir et il suffit de
lire chaque semaine dans la presse
l'écho de notes qui sont faites par les
renseignements territoriaux par les
services divers et variés qui alerte sur
le risque d'une explosion en france donc
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la
légitimité des manuels macron c'est
tellement effondrée dans l'opinion que
aujourd'hui son pouvoir tient d'abord
sur la peur qu'il inspire et cette peur
elle et elle est activée par des
policiers et on a un problème de fou
c'est que l'affaiblissement de
l'autorité présidentielle a atteint un
tel point qu'aujourd'hui les policiers
sont en mesure de dicter leurs volontés
au gouvernement ce point s'est accrue
avec l'arrivée de gérald darmanin qui
était sous le coup de mesures de
judiciaires ont en tout cas d' y avait
des affaires qui lui pendait au nez et
donc on voit bien qu'une façon d'une
autre on se trouve avec un ministre de
l'intérieur qui n'est pas complètement
indépendant des troupes qu'il doit
diriger et ça c'est un vrai sujet c'est
que aujourd'hui ce n'est pas l'état qui
contrôle la police
c'est la police qui contrôle l'état et
ça lorsqu'on se trouve dans ce genre de
situation on voit bien que d'une façon
ou d'une autre un darmanin
un castex un maquereau sont obligés de
cautionner des lois dont ils ne
choisissent pas foncièrement le contenu
c'est à dire qu'on sait bien que ce sont
les syndicats de policiers qui
aujourd'hui impose un certain nombre de
mesures dont le conseil d'état a dit les
limites et sur lesquelles il a attiré
l'attention pour leur caractère
disproportionné et aujourd'hui l'état ne
contrôle plus les syndicats de policiers
les syndicats de policiers contrôlent
l'état et ça c'est un vrai sujet c'est
vrai parce que ce n'est pas ça dans une
démocratie